-Welcome to the show,
Congressman.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-I want to ask about you this,
which must have been
a trippy night
for you when you won election.
It was 2016.
That was election night.
-It was.
-So a big night for you.
And yet a weird night overall.
-Well, I had lost two election
before then.
And as my brother says,
2016 was the year
anyone could get elected.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very nice way
of a brother...
-So I made it.
-...for a brother to say.
I want to move on
to some other stuff.
But I have to ask, like,
what has it been like for yo
this week with
the impeachment hearings?
Has it changed your take
on any of it?
And are you surprised?
Or is it what you expected
that it doesn't seem like it's
changed any Republican minds
-Well, that it hasn't.
But this is not complicated.
I mean, you can sum up the whole
thing in one sentence.
Donald Trump pressured
the Ukraine president
to dig up dirt on Joe Bide
and withheld aid.
And you got hours and hour
and hours of testimony.
But there's no factual dispute
I mean, we ought
to vote to impeach.
-There you go.
That was very simple.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And the Republicans, they don't
have a factual defense.
So they basically say,
"Okay, let's just attack
the witnesses."
It's like if your team is
losing, down 20 points,
you just attack the refs.
I mean, that's basically
their strategy.
-I think Washington
Congressional hearings
is always remarkable because
you know,
you see people elected
from across the country.
And some of them are good
at talking to witnesses.
Some of them are not good
-Right.
-You represent Silicon Valley.
And I think one thing that i
always notable to me
is how often,
when Congress people
are interviewing tech leaders,
they don't seem to understan
how even the Internet works.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the technology hearings
haven't been one of
the finer moments in Congress.
And there are a lot of
embarrassing moments.
But, you know,
when you have senators asking,
"How does Facebook make money?
Or you had one member of
Congress, he literally --
he held up his iPhone and he
starts yelling at Google C.E.O.,
saying, "Can you track me
if I move five feet?"
And the Google C.E.O.
is perplexed and says,
"Well, it's Apple
that makes the iPhone."
So, you know, this doesn't
exactly inspire confidence
given that we're the body
that has to regulate technology.
-Again, you represent
Silicon Valley.
You are also a co-chair of
Bernie Sanders' campaign.
-I am.
-So, obviously, that's a ver
progressive wing of the party.
You don't believe in this idea
of breaking up big tech.
But you do think
it requires reform?
Is that the right word to use?
-Absolutely.
I mean, here's the deal.
We're going through a technology
revolution in this country
Everyone uses Google.
Everyone gets packages
in Amazon.
But there's been a concentration
of wealth and jobs
and economic opportunity
in Silicon Valley.
The challenge I really believe
of our time
is how do we extend
the technology revolution
to rural America, to minorit
communities, to places left out.
No one should have to
leave their hometown
just to get a job
in the 21st century.
-Well, this is an interestin
situation for you
because I think it's very rare
for someone who represents
the district basically sayin
not that you want to
collect the power,
but you're basically admitting
there is too much power
right now in your district
-There's too much
a concentration
of economic activity.
And I'm probably
the only Congressman
where people are saying, "Look
there's too much traffic.
The cost of housing
is too much."
You know the average job a
a software company is 15 months?
I mean, how long have you been
doing this?
I imagine more than 15 months.
-Yeah, a lot longer than
15 months.
-So think about it.
People want to work --
If you want to work five,
six, seven years somewhere
a Silicon Valley company shoul
go elsewhere as well to recruit.
And it's a win-win.
It's a win for my district
And it'll be a win
for the country.
Look, Donald Trump went around
the country
and he basically said,
"I'm gonna bring
your old jobs back."
-Right.
-And the past is
better than the future.
We've got to convince people
that technology is gonna
bring new jobs, more opportunity
for their kids.
And that the future is bette
and something that they're
going to have access to
and the American dream.
-There are, obviously,
a lot of elected officials
because we have such --
there is such a big field of
Democratic candidates
who haven't jumped in yet.
You jumped in early as a
co-chair for Bernie's campaign
What can you tell us about
Bernie that we might not kno
from seeing him in public?
-He's got
a great sense of humor.
And I'll tell you
one quick anecdote.
-Because he seems very gruff
There are times where he maybe
doesn't seem like
he has a great sense of humor.
-I mean, he's not quite
your sense of humor.
-Well, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-But he's got
a dry sense of humor.
I'll tell you, you know,
when he was hospitalized,
I was going to be
speaking in Iowa for him.
And so I asked the staff,
"What should I tell people?"
And they said,
"Well, you tell them
that he had
a myocardial infraction."
-So instead of heart attack.
-Myocardial infraction.
And so I'm just Googling this --
What is a myocardial infraction?
And then I get
a call from Bernie Sanders
I said, "Senator,
how are you doing?"
He says, "Oh, I'm doing great.
He said,
"Ro, I don't recommend thoug
that you ever get
a heart attack."
So I said, "Alright, we're going
with heart attack."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And I'm glad you did.
I think for the straight talk of
somebody like Bernie Sanders
that's better
than myocardial infraction
-He's blunt. He's honest.
But the main reason I'm backin
him is his platform is simple.
He wants everyone
to have healthcare.
to have free education.
You know, one of the worst
attacks when people say,
"Oh, giving Medicare for all
is elitist."
Have you heard this?
-Yeah.
-I mean, the idea -- when 66% of
Americans want Medicare for all,
and if you're saying, "Look,
you're gonna get healthcare.
You don't have to pay co-pays.
You don't have to pay premiums
You don't have to
pay deductibles."
There are a lot of criticism
you could make.
Elitist isn't one of them.
-Yeah.
Well, best of luck with
everything going forward.
Thank you so much
for making time for us tonight
-Thank you.
-Representative Ro Khanna,
everybody.